[Musique]
bonsoir au
point ne fait pas attention les enfants
nounours est un peu bête ce soir mais
n'ont pas trop je ne suis pas peur c'est
une surprise ba ba ba une surprise
l'europe mon école pop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop on y voit là je suis peu
brown et moi j'ai terminé ma toilette du
soir bonsoir
où êtes vous
on était dans la salle de bain on veut
notre toilette
c'est très bien ça montrez vos mains
bref on est bien puisque vous êtes si
mignon j'ai une surprise pour vous si
galère qu'est ce que c'est nous allons
chanter ensemble l'histoire d'une drôle
de petit chef
et vous répétez après moi ma l'autre au
delà que green contenant
aurez vous une baisse trop plu
[Musique]
il était une chèvre de fort tempérament
du revenaient d'espagne et par le talent
le monde pas le temps de l'acteur
l'attendait dans manhattan la guinée a
dit elle entra par hasard dans le champ
d'un normand hélie vol un chou qui
valait bien trois fronts pas le temps de
l ena tombé dedans à la dague la guinée
et la codah poiron cantal et bien autant
le normand l'assignât devant le
parlement
pas le lot dans le coeur et nos temps de
temps à la
dette à la chambre s'y rendit et
s'assied sur un banc puis elle ouvrit la
porte et regarda de dental d'autant plus
que sur une tête dans des temps à la
lenga tard
elle vit comme son affaire à l'époque
tristement lors elle ouvrit la porte et
pris la clé des champs pas glop tonnes
de
co2 dans la tablette et des hôtels
[Musique]
[Rires]
le ta mise en jachère rechal a encore
une fin
au pardon patron j'arrive
je suis en retard les enfants on est
inquiets tu pas on va se coucher tout
seuls comme des grands on a l'habitude
quel enfant
exceptionnelle
pour nous ni
vanina noces
[Musique]
pas
bah
voilà notre big est lui non pas trop
c'est moi nounours
nous nous sommes bien amusés et bien en
route
mon gros nounours route bonne nuit les
enfants faute de bohain
bonne
[Musique]
oh
on